hello everyone welcome today to today's
live broadcast of less false negatives
quantifying cell viability by
simultaneous triple staining I'm dr.
Mike Kowalski staff application
scientist at beckman coulter and i'll be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by beckman coulter beckman
coulter life sciences develops
comprehensive solutions in laboratory
automation flow cytometry centrifugation
particle characterization and genomics
reagents to help drive scientific
discovery for more information please
visit beckman coulter calm before we
start here are a few instructions this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window at the
conclusion of the presentation we will
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button I would now like to introduce
today's speakers olivo kept received his
PhD in 2006 from the humboldt university
of berlin and the Max Planck Institute
for infection biology in berlin germany
is currently a research scientist in the
laboratory of guido kramer where he
investigates several aspects of
immunogenic cell death focusing on
systems by biology approaches allow suva
received his engineers degree in 2011
from the Asti to superior do beyond
sales in Paris France he is now a
research engineer on the bio cell
platform in village with France where he
is focusing on HTS essay and software
development for systems biology I will
now turn it over so Oliver and Ilan
for the presentations hi sing we on so
welcome to today's webinar the morning
good afternoon depending on where you're
dialing in from it's my pleasure to
present our bio self that film and
especially when I say multiplexing essay
that we have been developing and they
actually like it published in on go
target which is dealing with the
quantification of cell viability by a
simultaneous purple stain so as Mike
already introduced us my name's Oliver I
am the head of the bio cell platform at
the Institute piece of [ __ ] in Paris I
will give you a short introduction into
the technical aspects and probably the
decision making that we initially did
for during developing that platform and
then I will hand over to Ellen he's the
responsible research engineer here on
the platform and he will tell you about
the purple staining method that he has
been developing and publishing him
during the last couple of months um so
that's the beast so what we have been
building here during the last two years
and it finally has been inaugurated in
beginning of 2014 is what we call the
bio cell platform so in 2032 roughly one
year before the inauguration of that
platform we have been rewarded by the
provision Alliance of cancer research
institutes compactly to build a a high
school book phenotypic drug screening
platform at that time we swing the
market we got in touch with basically
all players in the game
and we got office and ideas from all
sides um finally we awarded the
consortium of Backman and molecular
devices which is two enterprises that
are under the umbrella of enlarging the
place that is called danaiah so
basically both of these enterprises they
belong to the same group which actually
made dealing with with with Batman and
Malaika devices at that time a lot
easier because in the end you were
speaking to just one partner instead of
many so at that time point we've been
swinging the market and the idea is that
that we got from Batman France
especially we were dealing here with
jean-claude from Harvey this was the
best the most flexible ideas in terms of
scruples in terms of redundancy and also
in in terms of the the conceptual design
was was was more clear than anything
else that we had seen in that period so
we decided to to build this respect mah
platform here so this platform so let me
let me disturb you shortly explain so
these platforms actually split into two
physical parts there is a shielded part
which is the multiplex weed out arena in
which most of the analyzers are located
and there is a second part which is
entirely sterile because it is
integrated into a steroid flow hood and
this is the compound management and
steroid liquid handling arena
so there's a large flexibility in terms
of workflows that can be run on a
platform it has initially been built to
conduct whole genome as I on a screens
as well as large small compound schools
large size small commencement so there's
two main roads main routes through which
material as well as selves and compounds
can enter the platform so there is a
white piece there is a plate hotel on
that side of the platform through which
all plastic material can handle the
platform and there is a biomech attic
speed on that side of the platform which
is doing all the cell biology upfront
the essays and upfront they're nervous
that station so the core of all that
cell biological campaigns obviously is
divine mcafee fxp on that site so this
is the core machinery that we use to
conduct cell culture of the plate
preparation as well as the charity all
the cell biology that is done obviously
here in this steroid compartment in this
flow hood is then stored for incubation
in two largest size incubators that are
integrated in that platform and there's
one on the bench incubator on this side
and another one on top here both
incubators together can roughly they can
roughly office space for about 200
plates meaning that this platform is
cable to run a whole genome screen in a
week so this is what it was initially
built for and this in testing during the
last couple of months intensely and this
works for the new phone um coming to the
analogies machines on the platforms on
that platform which actually makes it
capable of doing multiplex episodes the
main read out machines that we have on
the platform this is a multi plate
reader with a machine that can read
fluorescence absorbance and luminescence
in a very quick and reliable fashion it
though offers only a limited resolution
because it will come up with one number
per well in addition we have a Batman
sian flow cytometer integrated on the
platform which is equipped with the
hyper site or like notice so it can
reach waiting for word plates this
machine offers a higher resolution
because you get one you get one number
or actually you can even identify
different multiple parameters from one
cell so you not get only one number for
well but you get a couple of numbers per
cell and then obviously the highest
resolution is offered by these three
molecular devices like sand Excel
automated microscopes that are
integrated on the platform this will
give you access to subcellular theta so
looking at these three images the
molecular devices I speed paradigm
offers a very quick and reliable means
of getting an idea what's going on in
your system the cyan ADP can definitely
give you a lot of statistical validity
because it can analyze a lot of cells in
very same fashion to underline your
experimental findings and the molecular
devices microscopes obviously offer the
highest resolution and the best way to
identify you penalty
big changes that you might have given
not expected when starting your screen
the machinery actually looks like this
so we have the sterile compound
management and liquid handling area on
that side of the platform which is as I
said entirely shielded so you can see
the modem on robot here interacting with
the biomech ethics p on that side and on
the other side as I've said plat fullest
physically divided into two parts you
have this shielded multiplex V dot arena
so you've got the shield all run because
this modem and robots moving pretty fast
we have to protect the scientists
working on that platform that's why this
is shielded the front view on into the
laminar flow hood is depicted here so
you can see the biomech fxp on that side
which is actually equipped with two
bridges on one which we've got either in
96 or 384-well head in most cases we've
created forward head mounted for quick
transfer or as iron a transaction for
compound treatment and on the other hand
we put a spin aids that able to us to do
cherry picking for either via ray as I
anaise to Rhea Rhea compounds or to do
combination screens as alarms going to
tell you in a minute so the the bio
magnetic speed definitely is the cool
the heart of the platform because this
machine actually enables us to to do all
the treatments and all this cell culture
and all the plate preparations that are
necessary to conduct the screening still
we're doing here all these machines are
integrated by this monster on the right
side this is the the modem and
industrial 6xs robot which is on a four
meter rail and therefore it can reach
out to all the machines that are
integrated
to mention the main rid of machines that
we are going to deal with in that talk
today this is the the Sian adp of view
of the cyan adp so this is the 40-minute
fax machine the automated cytometer
which is equipped with this automatic
loader so that it can be integrated
forward plates and this is the three
automated microscopes on the right side
that we use for most of the SAS that
we're running here we've got the number
one and two you might see the numbers on
them that we pinned on them we've got
the number one and two which are
stationary on the platform and the
numbers we've is some kind of trolley so
we can use it for SI development while
the platform is running it's also
equipped with the life their chambers we
can do fancy tricky things with this one
works the number one and two this is the
working horses which are always going on
the platform and which when we use them
in parallel for running a for running a
screen obviously they they divide the
time that we need to image all these
images behalf for real large screens we
can even use the three images in
parallel which offers a very quick
acquisition of all the images necessary
to to go on with the animals this is not
done playing the movie place so you will
see in a second is the integration of
the machines via the mobile robot don't
move
you
so I hope you could see it for me it was
a bit bit buggy still what what this
movie showed rolls the modem on picking
up the necessary plastic ware from the
hotel and transporting this into the
laminar flow hood where then this
plastic ware is being equipped with
cells for the subsequent destination so
what we are doing on that platform here
is that we are creating data lots of
data mostly imaging data so this is this
is really a hard heavy data so we've got
the ex and ex-l machines three of them
imaging basically 24 7 we've got the
sign a DP creating also large FCS files
and we've got the ice cream basically
creating an exertion / an experiment so
this weekend illegally so all this data
is acquired and it's stored within an
SQL database so this is where data is
then processed firstly stored then we
use the workstations that we have here
which all of them are equipped with the
necessary and RV software so we retrieve
the data from the database we analyze it
and we write back to the database and
then we've got our scripts in place that
can send a database requests that can
retrieve the necessary data and can do
all the data mining and exploration of
the data that is necessary to understand
all the phenotypic changes that we cause
why are the compounds or by RDS on us
that we are using emailing all the data
is stored on a large scale dell server
and we also have an up texture that we
bought initially together with the eye
exams because there's there's very good
partnership between molecular device and
our tech and they furnished microscopy
solution together with the necessary IT
backbone so the artic silver is doing
all the calculations whereas the dell
service or storing and packing up all
data so coming to the assets going a
little bit into biology and the essays
that we're running here so what we have
been doing during the last couple of
years and months is that we have been
spending a hell out of time for assay
development so what we did is that we
would build a large-scale battery large
battery of fluorescent biosensors so
many of them we have established we have
stable established in human osteosarcoma
you do ourselves because they're just
gorgeous for imaging their large then
fled they're very robust and easily
genetic and can be easily genetically
modified so what we did is that we
constructed most of the fluorescent
reporters in lentiviral vectors and then
we transduce either the you to ourselves
or all kinds of other human and also
mouse tumor cells is those fluorescent
biosensors which makes life easy and
which makes life cheap as well because
if you consider running a whole genome
screening using an antibody staining
it's it's it's a it's really a lot of
money that you invest in in antibody
standings ways when using the biosensor
cell lines we can rely on the signal
that we get without any business names
apart from a simple oak stain to light
up in eclipse so we mainly use
fluorescent biosensor cell lines to
conduct our large-scale screens but
Ilan's going to tell you that we are
also because as I said these problems
very flexible and we can the depth to
all necessary workflows by east with
ease so Ilan's going to tell you about
the method in which we use chemical
stains to identify cellular viability um
the strategies that
we follow for most of our screens are
depicted here so either we do drug for
positioning essays meaning that we use
this bio census alliance that I've
showed you a second ago many of them
coupled to gfp then we do all the
necessary automation that we need to
scale up from the initial SI development
pilot experiments then we conduct our
screening campaigns so meaning that we
use the compound by briefs that we have
in house or what we got from our
collaborators of the NCI upon the screen
is finished we do a first quick quality
control checking that the number of
cells was equal in all the in all the
flights that we screened just looking
that screen went well then we go into
detail we do the hit identification
using our our scripts whenever possible
when interesting ballad hits come out we
do literal validations meaning that we
look at the phenotype that has been
caused by one or the other drug and we
try to reproduce this was another drug
hitting the same target we do in vivo
validations meaning that use that work
that we initially found and we use this
in people in animals that for which we
run the experiments here in house
because we've got a large Mouse facility
downstairs in the basement and whenever
possible we conduct retrospective
clinical studies so this is the workflow
that we have been following in a Science
Translational Medicine paper-free 2012
in which we identified career glycosides
as being very capable of inducing in
eugenics Elvis during cancer treatment
and there we actually had access to
retrospective tender data from the gusta
[ __ ] hospitals so we analyzed patients
that have received kind of like was that
during
can't freedom that they have received
here and we we control those with
patients that have only received
chemotherapy but no color black results
and we found that the patients that have
received actually tired like is that
during the human terrible treatment
because they were suffering of to
disease council and the heart disease
they were actually doing better in terms
of counter at least they were actually
doing better and they had a higher they
had better clinical prognosis and a more
extended lifespan as compared to the
ones that have only received another
which isn't amazing fun the other
strategies that were falling here mainly
is the on ice cream approach would
basically all of you know I guess so
again we use by a Santos alliance that
would happen if you develop we do the
necessary automation we run the
screening campaigns to the QC and go to
the heat identification as we do full
screens mainly the convolution meaning
that we get four to six only goes
hitting the same target and we they
convolute the pool screen that we did
initially and then we can validate our
findings advised as H on a 45 is more
more famous more shaker tin editing now
using crisper or Fallon conflux and then
we do the necessary rescue experiments
to public space to publish this in a
height so is this I would like to finish
the introductory part of today's webinar
I would like to thank our industrial and
academic partners this platform actually
has been built for two reasons one is
academic research and the other one is
being able to offer the drug spinning
platform also to industrial purpose many
of them like GSK Genentech Kalama
politics
kids have been collaborating with us in
the past and we have also been working
his academic partners here from the
Institute kausani and Paris obviously
from the booster for the Institute and
from other himself ridiculous who is
this I would like to thank the
organizers for giving me the opportunity
to talk today to introduce the technical
aspect of our platform and i would like
to hand over to L&L who's gonna tell you
all the details about triple staining
methods and about the multiplexing
capabilities of the vice of that from
here thanks so hello everyone so
thankfully we're for this introduction
to the platform so arm now that you are
unfamiliar with the platform we're
working on I would like to give more
details about one method within one
Hyperloop method we've been implementing
other platform which is the method that
a little quantifying cell viability by
simultaneous tribal staining so before
talking exactly about that methods I
would like to go back uh-uh on the topic
of sell their self because during the
last decades all the scientists agreed
on some facts but defining sell that
modalities is to the matter of debates
but during the last decade they all
agreed about about defining its thanks
to morphological changes and a
biochemical characteristic so now
assessing sell this is something kind of
is not exactly done in the same way in
all labs the most widely used method is
a simple method that fellow
distinguishing are dead cells are using
for example the molecule morphological
feature that show that membrane
integrity is it is corrupted and that
any die can enter of the cell which
would be rejected
we so this is what I call a 1d analysis
you're simply differentiate a debt cell
from a living cell but more and more
people are using a 2d analysis meaning
they are adding a dye that hello to
distinguish among the living cell to
dying cell from healthy cell because we
have been our weapon discoloring some
biochemical pathway that show that the
cell is doomed to die and here you can
see that i mentioned to our example
which are the massive activation of gas
passes and also the loss of trans
mitochondrial potential these two events
are show that the cell is doomed to die
and is dying and using 1g analysis and
distinguishing only living from dead I
will take this cell into account which
is a wrong way to assess cell viability
so like I said are we have been more and
more using 2d analysis but now we are
going to 3d analysis meaning we are not
only using two dyes want to distinguish
dead from living cells but also trying
to cluster healthy cells in different
categories for this purpose we were
using three different dyes we can see on
the slide so the pound stress but what
the cell can die so it's simply assessed
using for example the Derby the debian
die which enter the cells only want to
sell are the cell membrane the self
member and integrity is is the cell
membrane is destroyed can enter in the
cell and are fixed to the DNA to amits
blue fluorescence this is simply a way
to distinguish dead cells and among
leading cells are you can also
distinguish two different phenotypes
which is the loss of trans mitochondrion
potential as a mention above and this
can be seen using the dialogue the
dialogue die which which Emperor
spontaneously in the cell and
accumulates in the mitochondria when
this one is still working and as an
intact trans mitochondrial potential
when a mitochondrial from stress will
lock will lose our the the potential
their diet diet diet won't accumulate
anymore in the mitochondria and you will
use a diode signal and the third die
we're using is your pro simply a pound
stress there are some caspases that can
be activated activated and one of the
scale caspases is the cast past three
which is the effector of other cell bit
of some cell best modalities and this
cast as three can activate channels
which are called panics in channels
which lets the yoke pro as i enter which
will then fixed to the DNA and emit a
red signal we have been simply used this
free channel because they have given
their spectral poverty they are totally
compatible and they are no leakage from
one to the other regarding excitation or
omission so this line now is simply to
show you the necessity of fueling three
dies instead of two and even more
instead of one on the left you can see a
typical standard two-team analysis
effects analysis using the jackie type
which allowed to distinguish that cells
from dying or healthy and the dioxin
know which followed to December to
cluster healthy cells and here you can
see among alpha cells they're about 100
not 100 saw dat one person of alpha said
and if you add the new pro die to the
sem are to the same sample you will see
that that population justice clustered a
healthy is in fact is a dying population
and this this is something like fifteen
percent of the total evens meaning that
this 2d 2d analysis a
chem introduced wrong results by
distinguishing healthy cells which are
not healthy in fact so this was a
effects analysis which is all most of
the time regarding only the percentages
of this population and now we have been
also focusing of the absolute numbers
because we can have exactly the same
person pages and on population but with
different numbers and we've been
assessing these numbers are both with
facts and saito mia and microscopy using
molecular device I exam machine and
thanks to that machine we were able to
distinguish three are in the end five
different phenotypes so if you look on
top left you will have the dead
phenotype and a top right you have the
lp phenotype with three intermediates
phenotypes which correspond to the
diamond our statuses and in the 2d
analysis one of these three you can see
on the right was including healthy and
in fact it's knobs and they are the
graph you can see the barrage can see
down out the slide is a graph showing
the dose-response defects after
treatment with oxaliplatin asteras
following which are two drugs inducing
cell death the first one is inducing
immunogenic salvus typical self as for
beans to dying in our lab and store as
foreign is inducing is inducing a map up
to this even so we can easily see the
dose response which means which is
really beautiful showing that this
method is really accurate and if you're
interested you can also see the effect
of XIV ad which is an inhibitor of
caspases so it ended the apoptosis and
sell the store restoring effect you can
also see on the right of the breath so
now
presented you the method and the
necessity to you the 3d analysis for
assessing cell viability I would like to
show you how it has to be implemented on
the platform because from the essay
you're doing manually to the iphone foot
screen there are a lot of work to do and
the method has to be simplified as much
as possible so that it turns fiable
regarding the number of plates in a
number of condition you want to assess
so here you can see the protocol which
is followed simply on the platform we're
going to seed the cell using this multi
drug or device you can see on the left
after this after sitting and intubation
you will treat the cells and this is
where the meth method is really flexible
because this cell treatment can be a
chemical simple chemical treatment with
chemotherapy agents for example or a
metrics treatments which I took more
about the following slide to study
drug-drug interaction or sm interaction
srna transfection and so on after this
the cell would be invaded a certain
number of hours regarding the f'ing what
you see and the cell would be detached
in case of X facs analysis or nuts in
case of microscopy analysis and staying
off with a simple addition of medium
containing the three dice I've mentioned
before and after this staining which
lasts only 20 minutes you directly
assess cell viability using facts or
microscopy um so I want to go back on
the necessity of making the protocol as
simple as possible because here you can
see the the plan of the platform Oliver
showed you before and for only one plate
so one 96-well plate of privilege for
well played you can sing out all the
movement which are performed by the
the motorman the arm the robotic arm
that take the plate so you can see this
is kind of tricky even it so this is a
long there are lots of movements and the
length of movement is also long and this
is around 20 movement from the one place
so simply if you want assess some
hundreds condition you will turn to 20
flight so 400 movements which will make
the VSA really long fortunately all this
movement are controlled via the sami
scheduler which has which is which the
software written by beckman which
optimize every movement which is done
which is done by a semi and via the mot
minh and thanks to this software we've
been able to implement the method in a
hyphen facial so this show that we can
use um you can do the platform just as a
lot of late but the other point I want
to find out is that this platform also
allow you to perform really accurate
experiments so in a couple of minutes
you will see a video that explained that
show what I'm going to explain so I want
to go back of this famous matrix
treatment i showed you before the matrix
treatment is a treatment which is done
to study drug drug interactions so will
be if you have to drug you can have an
additive effect regarding service or an
antagonistic effect meaning that the the
effect of both drug will be less than
one and the other separately or impaired
hypersonic synergistic effect sorry
which uh which would mean that the
effect of both drug is higher than the
drug taken separately for this you have
to dilute the first drug are in
different concentrations so you have to
do raising castration of one drug and
raising saturation of the second drag
and mixing all of these drugs
to do a matrix of concentration and I
can assure you that this experiment is
really tough and hard to do manually
because this needs to be really accurate
and the reason is that after this we
need to build a dose-response market
model which has to been us as accurate
as possible to compute combination index
to study synergistic interactions and
are the biomech is so which is dealing
with the treatment is doing this this
thing in a really really accurate
fashion and you're going to see it on
the movie that done is going to play so
you will see that on the upper part of
the screenshot you have the mixed method
which has been written in semi and in
the lower right part you will see a
simulation of the deck on the biomech
which is performing the arm the metrics
treatment so down if you can please play
the video
you
okay so I think you old hearing I'm
listening to me now the video is down so
this movie showed you what the deck is
actually doing regarding cell treatment
and I want to certain mention that all
these wells which are typed it in the
plate of furnishing I tracked are
tracked by the robots and oh we can keep
the track of this of the well which has
been piped it's in the SQL database
which is linked to the Sami software for
further analysis and to keep a record of
all that is doing as that is done so
this R this treatment and so I'm going
to skip one slide and go back to it
after this treatment would allow us to
build what you can see on this slide on
the left so we have been using this this
method to study the interaction between
two drugs which are p g and c DD be
simply 1 c DDP is a drug which is
killing our community replication which
is used to kill cancerous cells MPG is
an any bitter of park park system which
is a system that allow repairing DNA and
we have been showing that cisplatin is
using this park system to kill the cells
so we were emitting the policies that
these two drugs together could i could
interact and have a synergistic effect
which was the case because so you can
see on the two curves that show those
wristbands for each bug so you can't see
that this is something really accurate
with small standard deviation and this
model are log linear model which work
including using our just to mention it
and this is something which is really
complicated to get manually and thanks
to this dose
since model we have been calculating
combination index for different for
different mix of drugs and we found the
result that in some some conditions with
no concentration these two drugs are
indeed synergistic so this was to talk
about really big surety of the platform
and now if you look on the right of the
slide you will see another essay which
has been performing the triple staining
method which is the aim was to to to
distinguish a differential sensitivity
to chemotherapeutic agent between three
are iso types of cells so white sap and
order which were mutated for some jeans
and we've been assessing three around
100k more therapeutic agent with three
concentration among three lines
incredibly Kate's you think this was
something like more than 1,000 and 200
wells and this was able to we were able
to do so with the platform in a really
quick manner and the results were
assessed using also a platform but a
virtual platform an analytic platform
using our so here you can see the
scatter plot that show all the events
from the DSA so all the information we
got from old drug treatments and in x
axis you can see the dialogue
fluorescence against my the first
intensity and we were able to quickly
cluster and count the differential from
every population thanks to a tool we've
been developing simply if you click on
the on a point on the scatterplot it
will retrieve the cell in the SQL
database its position and
surrogate the database and go check the
self image in the storage location and
if with that tool we are able to quickly
distinguish for example here on the
three cross are we are able to
distinguish three different phenotypes
of the cell and this is the the way the
tool we use to distinguish the previous
phenotypes I show you and this virtual
analysis platform can be used with any
parameter from facts or from microscopy
and for Microsoft think this is really
useful because we can not only use the
fluorescence from die but also assess
the shape of the nucleus or its size as
well as the different shape factor or
our elected facto it can be used to to
improve the clustering of data so in
conclusion I just want to say that this
method is really simple I mean the
protocol is really simple if you want to
do it manually and this can be easily a
scale up to scaled up to Roberto size
platform because I'm going simplicity
it's really flexible regarding treatment
or the device you're going to use for
analysis such as facts or mic or micro
squad and this is really accurate
because you're assessing absolute
sandlot viability this method is also
robust because they are reagan's where
you are well known and not pro
noticeable in from to the innovation
Plus this thing is really really fast
because it only lasts 15 20 minutes are
and this I said before this method can
be implemented to any platform it could
face facts or a microscope so that's
where I'm going to conclude for the
example so i would like to thank the
organizers for this is broadcasting and
I will leave I don't know
I will leave the yes it was peaceful
dealing with this we will be happy to
answer to all of your questions I would
suggest that Mike's gonna lead us with
the questions and the odds of those yes
thank you Oliver an alarm for that very
interesting and informative presentation
before we get started on the question
and answer session I would like to
remind our audience that you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window will try to
answer as many questions as we can so
the first question is regarding the
system basically it seems like it's very
flexible system where again it can be
used for any of three sort of difference
well or sell or subcellular level type
of data acquisition on the whole is our
most of the assays typically using a
multiple of these or are there a number
of assets that just use one or used to
or use all three of the detection
systems that are on the platform as is
that we are using of you can hear me so
most s is that we're running most events
that we're running here are using for
simplicity only one legal system but we
later on then go through the validation
of the initially found hit in Italy
found phenotype then we switch to
multiplex and essays meaning that we use
one two or even three of the analyzers
to validate excessive but the initial
screen normally is conducted is only one
winner most of the cases actually this
is the microscope for William great
thank you we also had a couple different
questions regarding a timing of during
of different assays so again and
typically for cell death essays timing
is certainly key obviously the shorter
or longer you expose things to compounds
or
Jean knockdowns you would likely get
different answers but it seems like one
of the very powerful aspects of the
staining technology that Ilan described
is that it may actually expand the
window in which you're looking
essentially so you're not only looking
at dead cells but you're looking at so
is committed to dying in the future so
you guys typically only run a single
time point and again is that due to the
kind of expanded window of the
technologies or do you typically look at
different time points or as most of that
just on in some lead-up experiments
essentially time we're running our
Challenger most of the time we are using
different time points this is a
complicated things to do so I didn't
mention it because our this is a living
si so the cells are not fixed so the the
entire method has to be as fast as
possible to avoid a cell deaths which is
not you to sell treatment but which is
due to the time the platform is going to
take to assess cell viability for that
reason we are defining offsets and the
platform is automatically assessing a
different title and offsetting the via
the treatment of the plates so that we
reach a really accurate time point in
the end and this is something kind of
complicated to do that will be managing
to do so these to say that indeed we're
always using different type funds to
assess sell this once we have found like
the best concentration killing
concentration and killing time point
we're sticking to this time point to for
the following or the following
experiments great thank you that
actually leads to the next question
there's a couple questions regarding the
staining dies themselves as far as
optimal concentrations of the dyes and
also are the dyes able to be used in a
kinetic fashion so essentially look at
different time points or over a time
course with a single edition and then
look after say every 15
it's or again it would be dies
themselves also a new cell death or
perhaps expire over time um now you
can't do so because are there is one by
which is first which is our which
sustaining the nucleus it's going inside
the nucleus and in Turkey only for the
work it's intercalating in the in the
DNA so this is is inducing a wreck ages
breaks of the DNA strands and is killing
the the cell in the end so you cannot
use you cannot just simply add the dye
and wait for in a kinetic patient you
really have to do one plate for one time
point ok thank you as there's some
questions regarding basically it looks
like maybe is there possibility to get
more information and maybe this can be
taken offline regarding the data
handling of the system or even if
there's kind of an average cost per
sample i mentioned that depends on the
specific analysis that's being done but
maybe in specific to the the triple
staining dies is there a rough idea of
kind of cost per sample is very much
depends if you would like us to run your
screens or would try this at home so if
you would like to work together with us
which of course who would appreciate
then there is a specific tariff occasion
system which has been put in charge by
the gist of [ __ ] institute so every
academic partner will have a certain
charge for using that platform if of
course you want to use this triple
staining in your lap new facility would
be happy because then my side does when
once you publish we would like to refer
to the trouble standing methods which
has been published in uncle target this
year which is in sabah at I paper on
qatar
2015 in there you will find for the
concentrations and all the references of
the dice at the youth the dice are not
expensive at all they're very stable and
they're widely used in most cell biology
labs on the thank you Mike great thank
you another question is regarding the
triple standing method does it
distinguish between necrosis and
apoptosis or are they basically both
considered cell death endpoints that is
a good question so being we've been
working more and more you are using this
triple staining methods and are just
regarding theory senses are so meaning
in facts actually it's kind of difficult
to distinguish the eye popped their
purchases from necroptosis however we've
been working more and more on the nuclei
features of and in microscopy trying to
cluster a different phenotype because
you know that in the club to this the
nucleus is getting bigger and bigger and
in the apoptosis in the opposite this is
shrinking this is shrinking and there is
so different phenotype we we are working
with which will be soon publish we've
been being able to discover and at this
now phenotype so regarding nuclear
morphological features a help as
distinguishes necroptosis from from the
apoptosis I'll actually while combining
this way guys you can easily distinguish
obviously apoptosis or necklace can
distinguish chelsea said apoptotic cells
and necrotic cells then distinguishing
neck protect cells from neck crop taught
excel so the program's way of necrosis
over way of dying by the closest this is
a little bit more difficult as alarm
mentioned we just play they have been
developing in microscopy based
methods and I say that soon can be
published by which in using this
combination of the eyes we can
distinguish help results from apoptotic
cells from necrotic cells from
electronic service thanks Mike great I
think we have time for one more question
and again I'll try and merge a few
different questions there's a number
regarding the different types of cells
that have been tested with this
application one has been asking as to
whether it's been tested with either T
cells some are curious about whether
it's been used with primary cells and
also whether there's been any attempts
to use this type of essay with 3d cell
culture for the imaging applications so
i could start answering that question so
this platform I guess I London we
specify for the clipper standing I say
so the platform actually has been used
with multiple types of services here in
self-monitoring cells even 50 results we
obtained from the east of racine
clinicians there also was one question
which I've seen here is if you can run
like a virus on that system and while he
began serving at least within within the
cabinets efficient as class to cabinet
so we can handle antiviral screens in
there as soon as everything that leaves
the shielded area is fixed and in
regarding the purpose staining essay
this has been done on different cell
types remember finish roasting
electrical staining we've been our
testing it up not more than two
different so like we've been testing on
established cancerous cell line from
humans to you to OS and been also
assessing our service in math or self as
well add MC a cell which are a cell line
from mouse and we've been also testing
its on monocyte
so a primary culture and it was working
in for all the cell lines we've been
using okay well with that I think we've
pretty much reached our time limit we
will certainly try to include answers to
the questions we have not gotten to when
we send out a copy of the presentation
but with that I would like to thank the
audience for their questions and their
participation in today's event I would
also like to thank beckman coulter for
making today's educational webcast
possible and most importantly thank you
to Oliver and Ilan for their excellent
presentations today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing on the
lab roots website for six months you
will receive an email from lab roots
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
for that announcement to your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
thank you again for joining us today
goodbye